Whoa wow wow wo woah
Hey, what's up guys welcome back I'm grant Thompson. The king of random and for this video
I have a little bit of a secret to share with you. I do not know how to fly a drone
I've never touched one before I've never operated one before and even though I have a commercial airline pilots license
I've never actually had the opportunity to play with cool technology like this so for this video
I reached out to a company called DJI
I'm sure you've heard of them
And I had them send me some of their newest products so the purpose of this video today is to share my personal experience from
The unboxing of a product, I've never touched before to becoming a confident and competent DJI drone pilot
Let's take a look at what we got I got three products from DJI I get their spark
I got the Mavic Pro
and I also got the
fpv goggles first person view
Now the idea behind all these the spark is one of the smallest drones is supposed to be extremely user friendly
Right out of the box almost anybody can use it
We'll see if that's the case the Mavic pro is a very cool piece of equipment my film guy mark has one and flies it
Around and makes it look very easy
so I'm going to see how I do trying it out for the first time and the
Fpv goggles well it seemed like a pretty cool concept as well you put them on and as you fly the drone you can see
What the drone sees apparently when you move your head the camera moves in whichever direction you look the camera also follows
So that's gonna. Be pretty cool to explore this video is not sponsored by DJ
I actually wanted to take it on as a project because as crazy as it may sound I'm a little bit hesitant of
Actually flying a drone never done it before I'm not familiar with it so this video is me crossing that boundary to becoming a confident
and proficient DJI drone pilot
And I will leave affiliate links down in the description in case you want to check out some of these products yourself
Alright, so we've just stepped inside from it so we can unbox these things
You will literally be seeing these for the first time as I do. Let's start with the spark
Looks like a carrying case that's pretty cool. Oh
Wow that's the spark oh my gosh, that is so small that is really tiny I mean if I stretch my hand out
They're almost the same size
Better like in every language of possible cool, so I just got everything out of the box
And here's what we've got a super tiny drone the DJI Sparkle
It looks cool came with a controller that unfolds it also compacts together very tightly
Takes a very minimal space I also got an extra battery
battery charger and a few cables and cords
Now in addition to that I got a few of these little bumper guards that I imagine go on the edges to protect the propellers
From bumping into anything inside the house making it just a little more user friendly. I'm gonna see exactly how difficult
It is to put these little bumpers on looking at it for the first time I can see there's little clasps here
and if I undo those clasps
Yep clicks into place and then
Boom, that's on
Put this back
I'm just gonna push that down twist it to the right and that is installed that was actually pretty easy even for me
There we go boom bumper guards are installed my DJ. Spark is assembled and ready to go
It just needs the battery to be charged
So we're gonna go ahead and assemble the battery charger throw the batteries on to get them
Ramping up and while we're waiting for those
Let's go ahead and take a look at the Mavic Pro the Maverick Pro has a 4k
camera and a
3-axis gimbal which gives it a lot of dexterity as its flying around and keeps your shots very stable if you've watched any other reviews
On the Maverick Pro you already know that it's very compact. It works really well flies very well
It's got an amazing battery life. It lasts up to 27 minutes per flight. It's incredible. It's very lightweight
It's very compact and it folds up to take up hardly any space at all and that's it boom
Flying 4k camera for the win. It's kind of cool
Looks like a little bug doesn't it like all folds up
Another cool feature is you can actually remove the plastic guard on the front and just let the camera fly by itself with nothing
affecting the quality of the image or you can just leave it on for safety and protection
Totally up to you
We got the batteries for the spark and the Mavic charging so our waiting. We're gonna look at the DJI goggles next
They just got the Box open the first thing
I notice is this nice white headset here
DJI on the front and it's got a little latch on the top, which is obviously a release mechanism for whatever connects in there
So let's take a little bit deeper into the box and see what else we find
Try to figure this thing out I found like a little halo band that obviously sits on top of your head
It's got something sticking out the top here. We take the goggles it looks like they will click right into place. Oh
There we go I just heard a click. That's what we need right there
Perfect those are on and locked
Now we got this nice little headset. That's going to go on and play with in a bit, but first
I want to see what else is in the box
Now that we got all this stuff out and batteries charging it's time to read the instructions so here. We are guys
It's actually the next day
And I do want to say with all three of these devices going through them for the first time it did take me about four
hours to get everything set up
so
I'm just gonna run you through the basics of how to set these things up and get them operational if you want a more detailed
Information I found there are hundreds of videos on YouTube that walk you step-by-step through the actual process itself
So here's what I did I start off with the DJI spark
And I downloaded an app called DJI go for and once it was installed
It basically just walked me through the process on how to connect this thing once the battery is installed on the spark all you have
To do is press the button once and then hold it a second time and the machine will actually turn on and then if you
Hold the button down for about six seconds you hear a beep once and then it beeps a second time and starts transmitting
Wi-Fi which you can pick up on your phone
I connected to the Wi-Fi so I can do all the firmware updates
I connected the controller and did the same thing and then I paired the controller to the drone using a simple tutorial I found in
YouTube for the spark and of course to shut these things down you just press the button once and then hold it a second time
And it will power down
Now as someone who's never seen this before I never played with the drone before it took me about an hour and a half to
Get all the firmware updated everything connected correctly
It was a pretty slow process mainly because I had to stumble through it so I would budget an hour and a half to two
Hours to get this thing fully set up and be aware of the space around you when you're operating it
You can use your phone as a controller
But I wasn't sure how to do that and I actually drove this up into the ceiling
Or it just bumped around for a little while and that's why you can see all the white weight on the blades here, although
It's still durable enough
I could still fly it without any problem at all
So don't do as I do don't press buttons you're not familiar with yet, or you may end up digging your blades
So that's the spark let's talk about the Mavic Pro
This thing's pretty much the same works on the go for app as well and once you download and install all the firmware and get
everything synced up
It's pretty much as easy as plugging your phone into this little USB
Connecter once you put that in with the app everything gets recognized it syncs to the drone
And you can start flying which is very cool finally
We have the DJI goggles these screens are in 1920 by 1080 resolution
Which gives you a really clear crisp image as you're flying
There's a little flap on the underside here that you can plug your USB
Connector into and I actually hook this up to my computer and downloaded some software from DJI to get these things synchronized once
They're turned on they seem to sink right to the Mavic Pro
I didn't have any problems with that and the coolest thing about using these is it gives you a
First-person point of view from the drones camera so you can actually see what it sees as you're flying
It's amazing when you put these goggles on there's a touchpad right on the side here
You can use to scroll around if you swipe down you can access the settings menu by hitting it once when you go into settings
You can scroll down to linked settings and then you can quick link to the Maverick Pro
It gives us 60 seconds to link up the drone
Oh if we flip this over and open this little flap on the back
You can see there's a little button in the top left hand corner if we take something sharp
Scissors are probably not recommended, but with we press that in it should make the connection
Lincoln complete
So this point everything is linked up and ready to go we have our goggles connected to the Maverick Pro
They can also be connected to the spark if you use a little
USB adapter to the remote control itself and the spark can be flown with the remote your phone or by hand like Jedi Mind Tricks
It's cool, and I'll show you that in a second
I got a Samsung Galaxy s8 and it fits nicely into the remote for the Mavic pro
I just had to take the casing off because that was a little bit too bulky
But that's a good fit and our headset is now connected as well so we can get that
First-person point of view and see exactly what the drone is seeing as we fly it around
Another impressive feature is the map that can fly four point three miles line-of-sight, which is really impressive distance
So now that we got everything set up and ready to go. Let's take them outside and play
First flight a success from here back in one piece that was actually a really cool view
I went up lift around the neighborhood a little bit saw us on the mountains off in the distance and it felt like I was
Actually there it almost feels like playing on Google Maps where you get to scroll out and just kind of zoom around except apparently
It's happening in real life
That was a trip
Now the cool thing about the spark is you don't actually need a controller or a phone to actually operate it
You can just get the system going until it powers up, and then you're gonna click the button twice point at your face
And it'll take off flying on its own and respond to hand gestures
as free
At this point all we have to do is stick out our hand the front lights will turn green
We can guide it like a Jedi
If I move my hand down it goes down. I move my hand back up it goes up and to the side
Now here's another feature. I think is pretty cool. If you wave your hand that it's saying goodbye
It'll actually back up to where you can take a selfie watch this
So, this is a pretty cool machine even without a remote control you can fly it using your hand which I think is awesome and
If you want to land it you just simply stick your hand underneath the spark and it auto lands right under your hand just make
Sure your fingers are straight, so you don't get them stuck up into the blade area
So there you have it guys the DJI sparked the Mavic pro
And the DJI goggles very very cool equipment that I knew absolutely nothing about going into this video
And now I feel relatively confident and very excited to fly these in the future in fact
I think I might have been bit with that drone flying
Bug if you know what I'm saying so now I've got my drones
And you can - I put the affiliate links down in the description
That should take you straight to DJI so they can get you hooked up. Thanks for joining me for this video fly boys
I'll see you in the next one talk to you then
I don't think it stopped and I make it stop
Cut the battery our disconnection works every time
Wow goes right back to that position, that's crazy
It looks like it's going down the pool